Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 14th,
2013 2013 and the year of our Lord,
Ladies and gentlemen,
and another week has passed.
I'm downstairs Sunday night.
Believe it or not,
this is why this podcast hopefully is up on time.
Hopefully I was able to upload it on time,
pass it onto the person who uploads it and they were able to upload it and you
were able to download it.
Now you listening to it.
Hopefully that has happened.
Um,
I'm down here.
Nia is upstairs.
She's watching the fucking Golden Globes.
Jesus Christ,
you know,
sitting in.
I'm like where my room is,
where I sit and stare at my computer and act like I actually have a serious
fucking career.
It's right off the TV place,
the room there and a for fucking two hours.
All I'm hearing coming out of that room as her watching the Golden Globes and
just one person after another just guy,
I want a crash.
You congratulate.
It was so brave.
Everything was brave.
Such a brave performance.
I,
your,
your unending courage,
your shut the fuck up.
Jesus.
You would think t's fucking people just,
I don't know what just won a war.
Your,
your,
your compassion for the human experience.
Your,
uh,
your,
the,
the intestinal fortitude of your fucking essence of your aura.
Jesus just fucking blows them already.
You know what I mean?
Literally Miles filling up with saliva as it just trying to get more fucking
compliments out.
I get it.
You know
how people sit there and fucking watch those stakes.
Let me ask you guys a question which you show up.
Would you show up to some shit like that?
If you ever got nominated for something like that,
you know,
did you go out?
What'd you go to?
The little Tuxedo place down the street.
Get yourself those plastic shoes that God knows how many people have already
fucking worn and gone out and puked in,
you know,
just stick your head through some fucking rented limo.
Sunroof.
Okay.
Woo.
When are,
when are right here.
You,
you eating that corn dog?
Go Fuck yourself nominated.
Not nominated.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we'll see right then.
You fucking have a couple of Michelob.
Um,
you walk in there,
the nomination for most original screenplay goes to Zippy zipper fest
and they play the stupid music and you've got to walk up there.
I can take away by publishers by uh,
I'm sorry,
I'm drawing a blank.
Uh,
my wife,
uh,
unended courage or bravery and putting up with me.
I know I'm not easy.
I know we keep using an English accent,
but it just always seems to be some sort of British accent now.
You know,
even like when you go on the Internet there,
if you go on the Internet,
how old did I just sound?
And they tried to explain something or sometimes when they have like a fucking,
uh,
what do you call it there?
Okay.
You call up and somebody puts,
you know,
you,
you get to the voicemail,
right.
They got that English accent going on.
I don't understand why they're there.
They're really in fucking vogue.
I,
which I went to Mike,
my favorite website that ted.com,
cause it always blows my mind with these fucking eggheads are working on.
And every once in a while,
something inspirational.
And today I went on there and uh,
I'm looking at this fucking lie.
Yeah.
Add a named Sue Austin.
She got sick.
So now she's in a wheelchair or as she calls it,
a power chair.
So,
uh,
she was actually psyched get to get in the wheelchair because I guess she was
bedridden.
And then she got in the wheelchair and she was like sight.
She goes,
I could fucking cruise down the street,
you know,
the wheelchairs they got now,
like those old people have,
they're not the same ones.
Like,
you know,
I don't think we've experienced our first death yet,
but if they make those fucking wheelchairs any faster like this,
you know,
it's going to be a lawsuit,
you know.
So anyway,
she's flying down the street and an inner in a wheelchair.
Evidently having the fucking time of her life,
feeling the wind in her face,
cause anything's better than laying in that fucking bed under all those
blankets.
So she psyched goes out in the world,
is having a great time.
Of course she's saying all this in an English accent.
If he didn't do window me face,
but all I need
all these cunts scattering about.
Um,
so anyways,
long story short,
she's taken it back how everybody like almost like ignores her,
you know what I mean?
Which I try not to do when I meet people in wheelchairs.
You know what I mean?
Like you try to fucking,
you,
you're looking them in the eye,
having a conversation,
but you can't help but feel like you look,
you're obviously you're looking down on them.
Then it feels like this weird like conduct condescending thing.
Like,
Hey,
you down there,
I'm talking he up here.
Right.
So what else you going to do?
You're going to squat down and now they feel like a little kid and you got to
tie their shoe or something.
It's really what they should really be some sort of standing to wheelchair,
um,
manners drawn up.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
That'd be weird if you that if you sit down too
or you then mocking their condition because at the end of the conversation you
can get up and walk away.
You know what I mean?
And all you're trying to do is not hurt the fucking feelings wherever dentally,
you know,
they're well aware that you didn't put them in the chair so that like just treat
me fucking normal evidently,
you know.
Can I say evidently one more fucking time this week?
Um,
God knows this.
Some do shout they're counting it.
Oh look,
20 to be a dick.
But on this week's podcast you said evidently fucking 40 rarely.
What did you do after you got done counting the evidence at least what was the
next exciting part of your fucking day?
You've got damn country.
Um,
so anyways,
back to the lady in the wheelchair.
So I don't know,
I kind of fast forward through some of the video,
right?
Cause I got to do this podcast and I'm,
she,
I know she got into diving or some shit.
Yeah.
Oh,
I know.
Somehow she could,
she,
I know she just starts talking about fucking scuba diving and how when you put
that shit on the APP rat tie that you go scuba dive in with all of a sudden like
the wheelchair.
It alters your way that you move around in the world.
But scuba diving was looked at,
he's looked upon is exciting.
So I thought,
what if I combine the two?
I know this is brutal accent.
So she basically fucking
put on a mask,
a regulator and a tank in the back,
put some fins on the fucking wheelchair and this lady had the balls,
the fucking ovaries,
if you will,
to scuba dive.
Okay,
so they cut to her going through the ocean.
She's got long hair,
it's hanging out the back float and she's fucking in a wheelchair sitting down,
going through the ocean.
It was beautiful and creepy all at the same fucking time.
It's kind of frightening.
I got to admit it was a little bit frightening.
Kind of reminded me a little bit of that movie mama that's coming out.
You know,
at that fucking tree woman that raised those two kids,
two kids get lost in the woods and then they find this,
this fucking creepy woman tree
dirty person.
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but I'm definitely seeing that movie because that movie,
that movie better not disappoint me because uh,
I saw the ads for that.
Do you guys see the ads for that Mama?
You know,
these two kids get lost in the fucking woods and this thing raises him.
And then I guess the humans,
you know,
find him and they bring the two kids back and they are out there for like five
fucking years.
And evidently the fucking dirty mother from the woods,
he's not happy that she lost her kids.
So she comes back to get them.
And um,
once again,
you people who are not into guns,
you know,
and you're against the NRA.
I'll tell you right now.
Okay.
I would love to hear what you add to say when some fucking half a tree,
half a woman dirty fucking individual comes into your house from the woods.
Ft.
Find Your kids cause you somehow lost them out there for the last five fucking
years,
comes back into your house and you're sitting there with a bread knife and an
English muffin in this fucking thing comes through the goddamn window.
Huh?
When did you want to have a semiotic assault rifle?
Not trying to cause a debate.
I'm just,
I'm just putting it out there.
You know?
She's trying to take a different angle on this
20 ways this lady is in a fucking wheelchair.
Scuba diving.
All right.
I'm terrified of the ocean.
Absolutely fucking,
I can't even say I'm terrified.
I'm informed of the ocean.
I know what's in it.
I know some of what's in it.
That's another thing too.
We don't even know everything that's in it.
And you'll get and you can't see it and you're going to go there and you can't
fucking breathe.
You've got to bring,
you've got to bring air with you.
Yeah,
there's a good idea.
Then fucking go someplace where I can't breathe.
Don't worry.
I brought some air.
Okay,
I want to go or I can't fucking breathe.
Everything's faster than me and if it wants to,
it might start eating me alive.
But don't worry,
I brought some air or these fucking people,
they're,
they're out of their minds and they don't deserve to be rescued.
I don't get,
I don't understand.
You know the Coast Guard I other than international freight because we got to
get food and shirts to people.
Okay.
Software.
So if those,
those people get in trouble,
I definitely think you should go out and try and help him up.
Okay.
But if you're just fucking out there,
you know,
beach blanket mango and you're out there surfing,
or you put on some goggles and you bring some air and you decide to go on,
do you,
you know what,
go fuck yourself.
We don't have the money.
Okay.
California 40 does now,
but we don't have the money to go save you.
This fucking state is broke.
God Damn assholes.
They got fucking Dui checks every three feet.
And why do you think that is?
Because they're trying to crack down on it.
No,
cause they're making a fortune off and catch.
And some people had a couple of Budweiser's,
you know,
I don't even know what I'm talking about this week.
So anyways,
this lady in the fucking wheelchair,
she scuba dives now.
Okay.
She can move her fucking legs and she has the fucking ovaries to go down there.
And I,
I,
I don't have the balls to do it.
I'm absolutely blown away by her.
But then on another side,
okay,
she's Kinda cheating because like if a shark comes at her,
she could just sort of lean to one side and all.
He's going to get as a mouth full of metal and you break all his teeth.
That would be great.
Ah,
you'll like that leg.
Good.
Take a shot at you.
Just fucking lean shark comes in.
Fucking knocks out all this teeth.
Fucking freaking out.
Freak out a shark.
Get him to put his little flipper over his mouth.
Like a little kid who broke his front teeth.
Okay.
I don't know if you see her.
I know that they're trying to make it beautiful,
but there's something about her long hair,
the fact that she's sitting down,
it's just weird and it's creepy.
Okay.
Do you know I keep seeing that dirty mother,
half a tree person,
uh,
with the leaves in her hair.
I actually like the downstairs in my house.
It's just creepy.
I don't know what it is,
is something that's creepy about it and I love it cause I come down here and my
mind starts fucking with me and I don't believe in ghosts.
I don't believe in monsters of,
uh,
you know,
other than just shit that we know that exists like sociopath's ax,
murderers,
grizzly bears,
and even a grizzly bears,
not a monster.
It's just hungry.
And I'm there.
Okay.
I would like that.
It wouldn't mommy and try and eat me,
but it's not sitting there like,
Whoa,
I'm going to fucking ruin this guy's day.
Doesn't have a just,
just hungry.
It's trying to get a sandwich.
All right.
And if I'm in its vicinity,
um,
like one of those sweaty pieces of Turkey that you see in one of those subway
fucking,
uh,
franchises,
you know,
I want to buy one of those things.
I want to buy a fast food franchise.
That's how I'm going to get out of this fucking business.
Yeah.
I'm going to buy something that just fucking serves people poison.
I'm going to buy it and I'm going to sit on the roof dress like the mascot.
Okay.
And I'm going to have a little bull horn and just real creepy as people walk in.
I'm just going to go ahead.
Go ahead
and just get that crease on your fucking oh,
your arteries.
Okay.
Big fucking clown shoes.
Yeah.
Maybe I'll just yell at them.
Dumb.
Fuck yeah.
Bring your whole family again.
Why is your mascot so mean?
Um,
when people defend eating like shit because they're broke.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
how much does an apple really cost?
You'd be surprised that shit will fill you up.
You get a banana for 25 fucking sense.
You can get 25 even as a few,
could be a fucking white dude.
Blue blood,
white dude in a suit.
If you stand there long enough going,
hey,
can I have a core?
I could.
Somebody give me costs.
So we'll give you a fucking quarter.
You've got a banana.
There you go.
You can ride that out til lunch.
Can't you starts raining.
You Open your mouth,
right?
You get some water.
Then what?
Then lunchtime comes around.
Lunch is tough.
Trying to beg for a lunch.
That's a rough one.
You know?
How long do you think your homeless before you look home with?
That's the crucial time.
It's saturates.
Got It.
It's like that,
that show,
the first 48
you got 48 hours before you look like you've been out there for 48 days.
So you got basically two days to somehow get the fuck off the streets.
Arouse your,
you're in it for the long.
You were in it for a while,
you know,
I dunno.
I Dunno what I'm talking about this week everybody.
I'm just trying to get this fucking thing done because I got shit to do
tomorrow.
I got shit to do.
All twinkle toes here has some shit to do.
Um,
my really 15 minutes then.
Well,
you know what?
Why don't we just do a couple little advertise was you got to this week
everybody.
Isn't that nice?
Let's get to,
we're going to do two right now.
We'll get them.
What the hell?
What is this?
Oh,
Jesus,
that's that fucking rip off.
Has nothing to do with the advertising.
You know what?
I'm the worst.
Okay,
there it is.
stamps.com everybody you know the drill stamps.com.
This will literally change your life.
It's such a great way.
If you new to my podcast,
if you go into the post office,
okay,
you don't have to do it anymore.
You can bring the post office right into your own,
your own apartment,
your own house.
Maybe they refinished the garage.
You know your parents let you move in after college.
You can show a little initiative.
Sign up for stamps.com everybody,
um,
think about how much time you've wasted going to the post office or how much
money you've wasted leasing and expensive postage meter stamps.com is the better
way to get postage.
Just use what you already have,
your own computer and your printer to buy and print official US postage for any
letter or package with stamps.
Stop,
calm.
Everything you would do at the post office,
you can do right from your desk at a fraction of the cost of a postage meter.
I've been using stamps.com for the last year,
sending out all my DVDs.
It's great.
Um,
I love it.
I feel like I'm a Philip.
I'm stealing money right now.
Get this special offer when use my last name burb Bu Rr for a no risk trial plus
$110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to $55 in free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in burpee.
You rr that stamps.com enter burr and I got one other one here.
I got one other one here.
She guys watching that football,
Huh?
The Americans.
Did your watch the football.
See what I did there.
I'm not talking football.
I was just stolen.
Just so I can get to the next ad.
I want you guys to hang in there.
See what fast forward.
Okay.
Ie voice everybody.
He voices what busy professionals use to save time at work to save time and work
smarter.
He Voice Converts,
converts all your voicemails to text and sends it directly to your cell phone.
No more interrupting your day to check your voicemail or waiting till after a
meeting to find out what's going on with he voice.
Your calls will always be routed to you,
no matter where you are.
Evil also comes with your own conference line for up to 94 participants on one
single call,
94 participants.
You could take over the world with a conference call of 94 participants.
All right.
Just make sure you stay,
you stay being the guy on top.
Now you want to be the guy second in command.
Guy On top always gets whacked.
Anyways,
it all starts for less than $10 per month,
but right now they have a special offer for our podcast listeners.
You can get eve voice free for six months with no obligation for your free six
month trial.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the program Promo Code Bill.
Um,
he voice can make your small business sound professional like a fortune 500
company.
They can create your own custom professional greeting.
Yeah,
they got like all these voiceover actors,
whatever you want,
whatever you want.
You want the English accent to sound professional like everyone else.
She got,
they got that.
Uh,
he voiced provides a dial by name directory.
So you'll sound like the big boys plus pick your own toll free number of sync of
what the number you have.
Now,
wherever you are,
people will think you are at the office.
Uh,
want to work anywhere.
Bubble bubble bloods he took just goes on forever.
He voiced you starting up your business.
This is it.
Go to [inaudible] dot com type in the Promo Code Bill and take your business to
the next level today.
Alright,
back to business here.
Um,
did you guys watch any of the,
uh,
oh,
you know what,
the tree person,
whatever.
I know why I keep calling.
Tree person just looks like the person looks like they made out of bark.
So when I come downstairs in my house,
it's the bags house.
Who's kidding?
Who?
All right?
I just,
whenever you buy something,
all you do is you just switch and landlords,
you know,
I want people to,
you radicchio people.
Jai I owed,
I bought my house.
No you didn't.
No,
you didn't.
You sold yourself.
You freed yourself from this guy,
and then you sold yourself into indentured servitude servitude to the 230 years.
That's what you did.
How old are you now?
Add 30 to that.
All right.
Yeah,
that's when you own your house.
Hey,
don't get mad at me.
I don't make the fucking rules.
Um,
so anyways,
with my bank owned house here,
this is what I do want to come downstairs and I get freaked out,
you know,
whatever the latest monster movie that comes out,
if it,
if it catches me and whenever I come down and the lights are out and I have to
walk into the dark room before I turned the light on,
I always pictured that thing being in there coming at me and I can really freak
myself up,
you know?
Same Way.
Like,
if I jump into a pool and I start thinking,
what if there's a little fucking alligator swimming right at me?
It makes me real quick to the side.
You know,
it's just your fucking mind play tricks on you.
So I know I,
I know how to get over it.
Now what I do is I walk in the room and I don't turn on the lights and I fucking
three 60.
Just give the whole room the finger.
That's what I do.
And I've never gotten killed for doing it.
If you want to get over that shit,
um,
I know I'm out of my mind.
You guys watch all this tough fucking great.
Where the games this,
I know there's a lot of bummed out fans because your team loss and uh,
I'll tell you right now,
I wonder,
who do you think age to more Bronco fans or uh,
Atlanta fans or Seahawk fence.
I mean those,
that,
those two fucking games where were,
were unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
And I know what a lot of people think of right now for all those years when I
trashed Peyton manning because they kept saying they,
you know,
they at that and start date,
despite Tom Brady's three rings and Pate Manning had zero at that point,
the guy had at the start when I still got to go with Peyton Manning,
you know,
um,
I'm actually going to defend Peyton manning.
That loss last week was not his fault,
okay?
Now I know that they had,
you know,
a punt return is something like that and that bullshit or whatever.
K,
the guy had a tip ball for an interception,
tipped off his own fucking receiver's hands for a pick six that's not on him.
All right?
Now he had the Brett Farve run right,
thrown back,
left across the body,
over the middle for a pick.
He did do that.
However,
the goat of that game is Rahim more.
All right,
you're up fucking seven points.
30 seconds left as 70 yards away and he stands there and they got no timeouts
left 30 sec.
He stands there like,
like,
oh,
what if they run it?
Don't let anybody get behind you.
So this fucking guy runs by Champ Bailey,
right?
Champs got him download this guy supposed to come over and have him over uh,
over the top.
He gets there late and they led Joe Flacco,
Joe Flacco,
who they keep telling me is this fucking amazing.
He even says it.
He even says he's amazing.
I see moments of it all right.
But I think he's been in the fucking league long enough to realize that he's not
amazing.
He is a efficient with glimpses of brilliance and I don't think there's a
fucking raving fan out there that would argue with me.
All right.
Okay.
I don't even think he's Tony Romo.
I don't,
he's just one of those fucking guys,
one of those guys.
I don't know what it is.
Sick.
Just you notice like how certain fucking teams that just good in one area,
they just know how to draft this one fucking position or maybe are just know how
to draft offensive plays.
Like look at the digize.
Nobody knows how to draft front four guys on a defense.
Like the fucking giants.
They're unbelievable Steelers.
Always have a great,
always have a great defense.
And then there's other teams that are just fast fucking teams.
They always have great wide receivers.
And then they,
I don't know the fucking ravens,
they just can't pick a quarterback to save that God damn life.
They can't.
So anyway,
so this guy fucking throws this ball,
throws it up for grabs.
Allah,
Eli Manning,
except he was actually facing where he was throwing it as opposed to turning and
facing the opposite,
uh,
end zone with his shoulders up.
Oh,
did it?
Did he catch it?
Um,
I'm fucking with the giants fans.
It was a hell of a throne.
Anyways,
so this fucker writing more and he's getting over there late.
Okay.
All of a sudden he fucking starts turning around because he looked over the
wrong shoulder.
And if a half a second,
he's running backwards.
He looked like a right fielder in little league baseball.
You know what I mean?
That kid,
please don't hit it to me.
And he fucking stops running,
jumps up,
misses the ball,
lands on his fucking ass.
The ravens do catches it.
Champ Bailey is right on that guy's ass,
but now because of raw,
he,
he had to hurdle that guy which gave the the ravens receiver and update.
You can see it a champs fucking body language.
When he hurdles over that kid,
you can see he's going to fucking score now and they scored.
All right.
What more is Peyton manning have to do?
They put up fucking 35 fucking points against the ravens.
That should be enough to win the game.
So I don't think that that's on a,
I don't think that that loss is on.
Peyton manning is far is like blowing the gang.
Yeah,
up by seven points with 30 seconds.
Fucking left,
70 yards to go.
That's on the goddamn defense.
All right,
so I know a lot of you guys thought I was going to pile on.
I actually felt bad for pate manning and I enjoyed watching them this year.
Now that he was finally out of a culture uniform,
I could enjoy watching them because I had major problems.
You guys know the deal with the colts crying about the Patriots?
We made a tape of it.
Yeah.
Sorry.
All the shit,
all that shit they're doing covering your receivers.
That's all legal.
Wow.
Then fucking,
I dunno,
change the rules.
Right.
And the fucking owner sits on the rules committee.
Next thing you know,
next thing you fucking know.
And the whole,
the whole game changed.
The whole game changes.
All office defense,
everything is fucking change because of the Goddamn cult because those fucking
cops couldn't beat us.
And that's why all Dan Marino's records of fallen.
That's why he starting to see Jerry Rice's records are being beaten by Wes
Welker.
You know,
that's why it's very rare to see it in an aggressive cornerback anymore cause
it's basically,
as far as I can tell,
it's kind of illegal to cover a receiver.
I've been through this shit.
So anyways,
now and what am I trying to say?
So now that he plays for the fucking Broncos,
I actually,
that was my prediction.
I said the Patriots are going to beat the text and said we're going to go into
Denver and we were going to lose because they had a better defense than we did
in our defense has been suspect all year.
Although they played great.
Uh,
they did play great today and it was still close.
You know what I think today,
I finally understood the prevent defense when I was watching the Texan in their
second to last drive where they for some reason had no sense of urgency and they
were down by three scores and I watched them,
the Patriots,
you know,
protected the sidelines,
kept it over the middle and those guys burned off like four and a half fucking
minutes.
Yeah.
And got the two point conversion and somehow they were only down by 10,
but all we had to get was a couple of first downs in the whole thing was fucking
over.
Um,
I still don't like it.
There's,
I don't know,
I just don't fucking like it.
And uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno what else to tell you,
dude.
I'm fucking burned out.
I watched so much God damn football.
You know how psyched is the head coach with is Santa Claus Hair?
This buzz cut Santa Claus fucking hair that Atlanta finally won one.
That was his ass.
Okay.
He would have to put his house on the market if they lost today.
That was it.
As they were up by 20 and they fucking lost to Seattle.
That was fucking it.
But I got to tell you,
man,
Seattle is the future man.
If they can somehow keep that team together,
that,
that's a scary,
that's going to be a scary,
scary fucking team.
And goddammit,
Pete,
Carol's a good coach.
Woo.
Ooh.
Didn't get to see him do that too much until the second half.
But a whatever.
Congratulations to all the winners.
Who Do you guys like?
Who Do you like?
I have no idea.
I kind of got to think,
uh,
I would say the 40 niners
God knows they were fucking kicking the Patriots ass,
but you always got to,
you always got to figure bill Belichick,
you know,
once he's seen you once that said,
plus all the shitty films.
I mean,
you got to think we might have you the second time around,
but that's provided.
We can get by the ravens.
All right.
Can I do my dumb Espn Shit?
Uh,
Bill,
what do you think the keys to the game dish?
I think it all comes down to Joe Flacco.
All right.
I think,
I think we have,
I think we can somehow contain ray rice so he won't kill us too bad.
Hopefully he won't rip off an 80 yard touchdown.
Carry on the first God damn play.
But a,
it all comes down to Joe Flacco.
Is it going to be bonehead Joe Flacco or is it going to be the Joe Flacco they
keep telling me it's going to fucking show up each week.
All right.
If the prodigy shows up,
we could be in trouble cause everybody knows the ravens.
They all know they're fucking defense.
And by the way,
I'm sick of people talking about Ray Lewis going,
yeah,
can he just retire already and get on?
Go back to his murdering career.
Um,
he was never convicted of murder.
He was initially going to be charged and I think you might've been shot.
Was he charged?
He was charged with obstruction of justice.
He pled guilty to that to make it fucking go away.
I Dunno,
I looked it up on Wikipedia.
It is kind of shady.
I Dunno what happened.
It was,
he had some sort of John Travolta white suit that was never recovered from that
evening.
Um,
I dunno,
I never believe any of that shit.
He was also a fucking multimillion dollar athlete in a fucking club and some
shit went down said God knows they're going to drag him into what the lawyers
will anyways.
Right.
Hey Bill,
you have to think about talking about shit that you know about instead of just
running your goddamn mouth.
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
I'm excited about all these new quarterbacks that are coming in that uh,
Colin Kaepernick and Russell Wilson,
man,
those guys,
I was kind of looking forward to seeing those guys square off,
but a B in a Boston guy,
I'm glad a BC guy one.
Um,
but uh,
my prediction,
somehow the Patriots were going to squeak by the ravens.
I'm going to age like nine years and um,
I don't think the 40 niners are going to have a problem with the ravens.
The ravens with the,
with the falcons.
I think they're too deep.
I think that quarterback is not even remotely nervous.
I think he actually enjoyed,
he actually said that he enjoys playing in close games.
I think the 49 has got their guy,
they have a fucking beast on the horizon here.
And this is another wave of new quarterbacks coming in and somehow Brady and
Peyton of the old guys,
now it's unreal.
And I'm older than all of them.
All right,
I'm with the podcast here.
Um,
I know it's gonna be a lot of people disappointed that I didn't trash Peyton
Manning,
but you do.
You understand what I'm saying?
That one isn't on him.
It's not on him.
But what's funny is now,
after these years of me talking about his play off record saying all that shit,
they're finally bringing all of that up there.
Finally saying what I've been saying when I'd now don't hate the guy anymore.
You know,
now I'm watching ESPN gone.
Ah,
Geez.
You don't have to bring that up.
I'm a fucking nut.
So anyways,
um,
this is the big exciting thing in my life.
You know,
I've,
I've finally got this fucking house,
somewhat shipshape an asshole.
I bought an old house,
you know,
and when you buy something old it's just constantly falling down.
Like I actually had to turn the heat off because it's loud as fuck.
And I looked up and I said,
oh I can actually adjust that vent that looks like he was putting in like 1975,
you know,
some sort of Brady bunch era of vent that's in the ceiling.
So I go up there and I sh I go to shut it off and it's so fucking old.
It can't quite close.
It can only close to the point where the hot air is now whistling through the
vents.
So my options were either to leave it full blast drying out what's left of the
top of my head.
Um,
both hair on top of my head having it whistle or sit here in the cold,
which is what I'm doing,
you know?
Oh Shit.
Is that fucking tree lady going to show up?
Cause it feels like it's outside coming up here with leaves in her fucking
Bush.
I have to go see that movie.
Why is it crawling around on the floor?
Oh,
I speak at a movies,
oh,
there's a segue for you.
MMM.
Ben Affleck,
one for a,
um,
Argo and I was looking at it up there online and evidently I ran,
was less than thrilled with his version of what the fuck happened in Argo.
So evidently they,
evidently,
I said it again.
They're going to make,
did they're gonna make their version of Argo.
All right.
Any movie nerds out there who listened to this podcast,
please stay on that.
I want to watch that movie.
I really want to watch that fucking movie.
I want to see their version of what they think happened.
You know,
we got the Hollywood version.
Why shouldn't we get the,
uh,
on version that's what they should start doing.
Or I think around the world when a big Hollywood movies make movies about other
countries,
that countries should just pull their money together in an adorable way that all
the little insignificant countries around the world,
you know,
I mean it was,
couldn't,
no,
there's only like this like three real countries like the world is,
it's kind of like baseball where this like,
you know,
this like six teams,
they're going to be competing for it every year and the rest of you,
you like the brewers,
you know?
Okay.
Hey,
you want me to be the ignorant?
I'll fucking play it up.
I'll bill stop acting like you're dumb when your shit down.
We all know you Erika.
Fuck,
you're right.
You're right.
I'm done.
So anyways,
I've been trying to uh,
also and it stay on that please for the love of God.
Stay on that.
And I ran.
If you're listening.
All right,
don't fucking pussy up.
Make that movie.
I want to see it.
I think it's great.
Let me see your lives.
Let me see what you got to say about what happened.
What's your version going to have
those six people are rapists or were they friends of yours and you actually
helped them on the plane?
I want to see it.
All right.
If you could just,
you know,
okay.
Take time out of hating and just make a movie.
That's,
that's actually bad.
I shouldn't say that.
Not everybody hates over there.
There's gotta be an Iranian bill burst sitting there trying to podcast.
I saw it.
I saw a documentary on kids who play heavy metal and metal music and trying to
be in a fucking band in either Iraq or Iran.
I forget what it was.
It was really interesting.
So there we go.
Let's,
let's fucking cap that ignorance right there.
Bill.
20 ways I own this.
I own this old house.
Okay.
Uh,
this old house is a piece of shit.
This old house has a bunch of plaster that Abraham Lincoln fucking put in the
bid fucking eight,
16.
Um,
so I'm gradually getting this thing.
I had to fucking do the guts first.
I had to do the wiring and I had to do the plumbing.
And by saying I had to do it.
I mean I hired another man to come over and do what I don't know how to do.
So I think I got it shipped shape.
I think I finally got rid of the last little bits of galvanized pipe.
I got everything thing in here.
Now it's all copper,
right?
So I don't even want to green or Brown fucking water.
Yeah.
I got most,
most of the uh,
electrical done,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't what was going on did we had some sort of fucking exposed wire near the
gas and we literally could have blown ourselves up every time we fucking use the
fireplace or something.
So got that straightened out last week.
You know,
we,
we got,
uh,
we got dish rather than cable and a,
the last people here had cable.
So I'll tell you right now,
two fucking people that I can't stand and to people that you won't be able to
stand when you fucking get a house.
Our painters and the cable guy.
All right,
the guys who install cable,
these fucking conch.
First of all,
painters,
they paint over everything.
They don't give a fuck.
Door knobs,
hinges,
doorbells,
windows outlets.
Okay?
If it's a fucking kid,
lean it up against the wall.
They'll fucking bill paid over at did.
They'll go up,
down,
up,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
We'll give it the kid three swipes before they realize,
oh wait,
this is a living thing.
They'll paint your fucking dog.
They don't give a shit what color you want it all right,
everything.
Why don't you just grab the bucket of paint,
take the lid off and then just start spinning around with it.
Cause that's what the fuck you're doing.
You know?
Then I got to go in and clean up your goddamn mess.
So anyways,
and then the cable guys,
when they install cable,
they basically unload like five miles of cable.
They completely overestimate what they need and then they grab a fucking drill
and and a staple of some sort of staple gun.
They called case went case when cash up the side of your fucking house.
And then whatever's in their way,
they just drill through it.
So I spent like three hours the other day climbing all over my house,
getting this shit off,
you know,
now I got to go,
go back with like fucking stucco and whatever the fuck I gotta do and patch up
some of these holes,
you know,
some of the nails came out and took a chunk of this shit out
through all of that out.
So now,
you know,
spackled the walls repainted them.
I'm all fucking good.
So now I get to do the fun shit.
I get to actually work on something that you can see.
So,
uh,
we got these doors upstairs.
I've got like five doors upstairs.
Three of them are original from the old days and in two of them are home depot
specials,
which basically means an eight year old having a temper tantrum could put his
little fucking eight year old hand throw him.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
I actually found a place where they have all these old fucking vintage doors and
it's made of the old shit.
You know,
when you fucking knock on the door,
makes that solid sound as opposed to that shit sound.
You know that Ikea sound that's Ikea.
You hear that?
Wait a second,
that's Ikea
here.
Can you tell a difference?
Well,
you know what,
go fuck yourself.
I can
but his,
his,
or some Ikea.
Here's some Ikea right here.
Here.
It,
that.
I have no balls here.
That,
that fucking word
that you know,
I key it gets there.
What they basically like you ever see those popsicle stick houses?
They have Cambodians make those,
but instead of like a house,
they make a dresser out of it.
That's what they do.
And then just unscrew it and they ship it over here.
Um,
so when he was,
I found these old fucking doors and are,
they are in rough shape and ain't going to lie to Ya,
but,
uh,
I'm actually gonna attempt to refinish these fucking things.
So if anybody out there knows,
what can I use to take the paint off?
I don't want to use this sander.
I didn't want to fuck the thing up.
All right.
My Dad was telling me they got this goop.
You could just paint on it.
You walk away,
you come back,
it shrivels up and then you just fucking wipe it off.
Does anybody know what the name of it is?
This is what I do when I do this shit.
I asked somebody I respect like my dad and then I asked like fucking 20 other
people and then I just,
I put it all together.
Okay.
Built.
We really don't want to hear about you.
Re fucking doing you.
How?
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
let's,
let's get,
let's get to some emails for the week,
shall we?
I'm still at a Christmas mood.
I didn't trash fucking paint.
Manning.
Um,
India's rebuttal.
Do you remember a few weeks?
I'm not reading that fucking one.
I'll get to that one in a second.
A professor wants to bang.
Hey Bill,
I'm a 19 year old male college freshmen and my professor wants to have sex.
Do it.
I'm sorry that wasn't me.
That was somebody else yelling.
Okay,
I'm going to be a professional.
I kept getting these signs ever since the first few weeks of class began.
You're 19,
you're an adult.
Right.
And I'm not really,
I can't get in trouble here.
Right.
Um,
I noticed anytime I am running late to class by a few minutes,
she would always wait for me to start class
through get to the good part.
What does she look like?
Um,
every time I walked in and she would say things like,
oh,
I was worried you were sick and I was worried you were going to miss my class.
Jesus,
she's putting it out there right in front of the whole class.
Um,
anytime any l anyone else is late to class,
she ignores them and starts on time.
Well,
wait a minute to it.
Or you're the teacher's pet,
uh,
you know,
when she says sal,
did everybody do the reading last night?
Do we,
uh,
have any,
any thoughts on the assigned material?
Everyone just sits there staring at her,
chew their gum slowly and you actually put your,
your your hand up.
Oh Michael,
what do you have to say?
I found it.
I thought it was brave.
I thought it was,
it was exquisite,
you know?
All right.
Let me want to just read the rest of us here.
Anytime.
Anyone else's late to class.
She,
she,
she ignores him.
Starts on time.
Okay.
She's always over the top.
Nice to me when we see each other.
I brushed this off and I didn't let it get big in my head.
All right,
so he sees he's sick.
He's not thinking that this going to happen.
Okay.
A telltale sign came to me one day when I was small.
I was at the smoking section on the campus after I left her class,
I cheated word for word from the girl that sits next to me in class on a test I
had just finished.
The girl that sits next to me came down to the smoking section with a bag of
chocolate in her hand and gave it to me.
She told me our professor gave it to her to give to me.
Yeah.
Boy,
they're trying to bang.
Your teacher is like trying to get away with a murder.
The more people who are involved,
the bigger chance you have of getting caught.
So what the fuck is she'd given this girl shot the for bringing her in the fall.
Fox.
She wants a threesome,
right?
Is this,
is this,
where is this where it's going?
Please tell me it's going in this direction.
He's like a red shoe diaries.
Um,
I asked the girl if our professor gave the chocolate to the class when I left
and she said,
no,
I tried to keep calm.
Thank you.
We'll say as my dick was filling up,
I try to keep calm and asked the girl how she did on the test.
MMM.
I told her I copied her word for word and she said she thinks she did.
Okay.
A few minutes later our professor came down to the smoking section where her car
was parked.
The girl asked the professor what,
what she made and the professor tells us she made a 74.
When I asked her,
she flipped her hair,
smirked at me and told me I made a 94.
Wow.
Okay.
I'm going to tell you right now,
right fucking now if this happens,
dude,
you were two condoms.
This woman is reckless.
Okay.
Go ahead and bang.
You're fucking teacher.
Do it towards the end of the semester.
So bad.
Anyways,
she's 36 years old and divorced.
MMM.
On this certain website,
wherever Denley people can uh,
basically rate their teachers.
The students rated her as hot.
I want to ask her out to lunch sometime.
Dope.
She's 36.
Just fucker.
She didn't want to go to lunch.
She's 36.
She wants lunch.
She'll buy our own lunch.
But that's,
you know,
you're 19.
I keep forgetting that.
Anyways,
the only reason why I haven't asked her out yet is because she told me she has a
13 year old daughter.
We,
oh,
that's the sound of her vagina.
She already got a kid.
[inaudible] oh,
uh,
my,
my question to you is,
would it be wrong?
There are other girls I have met,
but they are the typical dumb whores you find in college.
Okay.
All of them.
I wouldn't think every girl is a dumb whore.
Is every guy a dumb jock?
Is every job dumb?
See what happens when we talk in absolutes.
Um,
I am not saying I want to marry this broad,
just a one night stand with the history.
Uh,
the professor would be nice.
I am not the type of guy that likes to go around and fuck as many girls as I
made.
That is why I keep thinking that she has,
that she has a daughter and I should probably stay away.
What do you think?
MMM.
I Dunno dude.
The fact that you hit your,
which did you don't want to fucking do what I,
I don't know.
Well listen,
do you,
do you know how to bang a girl and then fucking see you the next day and have it
all be cool that that's a skill,
you know,
and not have her feel like you used her or whatever,
you know?
Do you know how to do that?
Hmm.
I can tell you one thing you don't want to do is,
what I would do was,
was the next day I'd be like,
Hey,
oh fucking weird.
And then they get mad and the next thing you know,
all of their friends are fucking looking at you like you're a Dosha and they
start drawing right and shit on your locker.
US A fucking nightmare.
Um,
okay.
If you've mastered the art of how to fuck somebody and not be,
I don't,
you know something dude,
if you're going to fuck this girl,
you have to do it at the end of the semester.
Once it's over.
Um,
this girl,
she's reckless.
She's a nightmare.
If she's fucking putting this out,
it's unbelievably unprofessional.
She should be way more discreet.
Okay.
All right.
And you cheated on this girl word for word she gave you 20 points are,
you know what,
dude,
stay away from this girl.
This girl is,
is she's going to get fucking pregnant and you don't want it to be you.
All right.
Who doesn't want to fuck a teacher?
Everybody does,
but she knows something.
You don't want to have a fucking eat.
I wouldn't do it.
Don't do it.
Okay.
Stay away.
Why don't you go meet some nice girls to stop talking to dumb horse and uh,
you know,
yeah,
I dunno.
Rub One out before you go to class and really think about it and then let me
know what happens.
Okay.
All right.
Hate people considering Florida.
Wow.
Okay.
You don't like people and you want to go to Florida.
You're either going to totally fit in or commit mass murder when you go down
there.
Bill.
Hey,
huge fan.
I've been living in New York my entire life and now that I'm working in New York
City,
all I can say is that I hate people.
I agree with you that the population is way too big.
There simply way too many assholes out there.
I consider myself a decent person,
so I am not all high and mighty,
but one thing that is important to me is respect.
I commute to New York City every day and all I can say is that the majority of
people are assholes.
Nobody has simple manners anymore.
Nobody says thank you.
When you're,
when you hold the door,
nobody even holds the door.
People are obnoxious on the phones and public places,
et Cetera.
Even out driving people are dicks.
People cut you off and then tell you to go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
that might've been me.
I do that all the time.
Okay.
Look at this fucking guy.
He's on his fucking phone after I was just on my phone cutting off the person
that I'm now in front of.
Um,
I am emailing you because I listen to your podcasts every Monday on a here.
What kind of advice you give?
And I like it because you,
you are being honest.
I hate.
Oh,
thank you.
I hate the people so much here that I'm considering moving to Florida once I get
married and start a life there.
I was 24 years old,
have a great job,
have a great girl and I am miserable simply because of other people.
Um,
my girlfriend hates that I am like this,
but I keep telling her there's nothing I could do.
I am just like,
I'm just like,
that just keeps telling me that if I continue like this,
I'll eventually become a bitter person and she is probably right.
Yeah.
And you're going to end up losing her because who the fuck wants to be tied to
that?
Uh,
he,
I have gone to Florida many times and love the southern hospitality people seem
just happy all the time and I want that my girlfriend's parents bought a house
down there recently and we've off and have offered us to live there to try it
out.
Of course,
after we get married,
I know it'd be a big steps and said would it be leaving behind my family and
friends?
But I feel like I need to do something this drastic to keep my sanity.
The only bad thing I hear about Florida's to job markets,
but I will soon be a CPA.
My girlfriend is finishing her masters in education.
So I think as professionals in our field,
we should have no problem finding a job.
If you are in my position,
what would you do?
Am I just overreacting?
Am I just crazy?
Thanks in advance.
MMM.
Oh fuck
yeah.
What would I do if I was you?
Um,
I dunno dude.
I just can see you moving to Florida or going down to Florida and looking
through rose colored glasses thinking it's the shit.
And,
and then you're down there and you're in your house and you got your little
fucking job or whatever,
and then you're going to start hating the people down there with their pony
tails and they're fucking Miami vice tank tops.
Um,
their criminal records,
the meth problem,
the alligators,
the fucking brutal,
brutal,
brutal humidity.
The mosquitoes the size of a fucking golf ball.
Uh,
yeah,
I mean,
did some nice places in Florida.
And then there's the rest of Florida.
Okay.
It's either,
it's,
yeah,
it's a different deal dude.
And they just being an east coast guy and coming down from,
I dunno,
I mean,
but you're a young guy.
It's one of those things that it's,
it's something that is recoverable.
You can definitely get out of it.
I would more be more apt to tell you to go down there if you were single,
you know,
go down a single,
get a fucking flop house to stay in,
check it out,
see how you like it.
But just know that when you leave,
you leave in all that food,
you'll leave it,
all that culture,
you'll leave in all your sports teams.
Cause you say here,
by the way,
thank God hockey is back.
I can go back to not giving a shit about basketball.
Go island is fuck the rangers.
MMM.
You're going to miss that down there,
dude.
You're going to have the lightening,
which is actually a great fucking franchise,
great franchise.
And you have the panthers.
So,
um,
yeah,
I dunno man.
You just got to,
what would I do if I was you?
Um,
I would get,
I would learn to figure out why.
It's actually something I'm learning how to do.
I'm so,
I'm trying not to have
let people affect me is that much like I love living in la in every time I get
my fucking car
it takes me about,
sometimes I don't even get off my street and I yell at the person in front of
me.
I just go,
just fucking go.
Okay.
And then I left going like,
dude,
you didn't,
you I can still see my house.
I'm already this mad.
Okay.
And I sit there talking to myself going,
they had the worst fucking driver's.
Oh yeah,
go slower.
Slower.
Yeah.
Take it,
take all day.
All Day.
There you go.
They slower slow it down.
Yeah,
I hit the brakes when they go to make a right turn.
These people out here like that whole,
I mean you said you liked the southern vibe.
Like you know,
we're on the front of the beat.
If you look at it musically,
you've got the front of the beat on the beat and then laid back at the back of
the beat.
We East Coast fucking people meeting Boston,
New York,
Philly,
we're fucked.
We get to DC.
Start getting a little bit of that sadness.
Little bit of it,
little bit of it sneaking in layer.
But W we're fucking like we on your shit.
No Huddle fucking full court press.
That is our energy.
So just know that you're going from that to like a Yay.
Sit down there man.
Have yourself a biscuit.
Let me tell you a story.
You know,
they just fucking,
you know,
arm out the window.
I got all fucking day.
Just no sense.
No sense of urgency like the Texans on their second to last drive.
Uh,
dude,
I would definitely go down there and check it out before you do and really think
about all this stuff that you're leaving behind and that whole thing that,
you know,
me and my wife are going to be professionals.
The job market should be wide open.
When I think of Florida,
I think of foreclosed homes.
Like those people really got fucked down there.
Uh,
there's a lot of you,
I check out the job market before you get down there.
Before.
I don't know if the only thing you got going for yourself as you're 24 so you
can still go for broke at that age.
But,
uh,
I dunno,
I would learn to like people be a little more tolerant because you're going to
go down there and eventually,
what do they say about Florida?
Sunny place for shady people.
You know,
it,
that's sort of like you're going to run into a lot of people look like dog,
the bounty hunter when you're down there.
All I'm saying,
unless you go to fucking Miami.
Anyways.
Hello Mr [inaudible].
Uh,
what does this pathetic cheater?
I am currently a high school freshmen.
My dilemma and or issue is my father hit my mother and married and had been for
the past six years.
My,
okay.
Okay.
So this is my obviously a second marriage here for somebody.
Uh,
my mom has been divorced.
There we go before with my brother's father.
Oof.
This is like one of those math problems.
If a train is leaving,
um,
she married my dad when I was seven probably.
Did you just like dictate this and somebody like typed it out?
This is very conversational.
She married my dad when I was a seven probably.
She stayed with him through a lot of physical fighting,
previous cheating,
and she believes he's still a good guy.
He's currently unemployed and has been for almost three years in claims.
He's sick of not working,
but every time my mom tries to apply him for a job,
he gets an attitude,
which I think if you're a male and you're not the provider of your family and
are in no rush,
no rush to be the provider,
it makes you a bitch of a man.
Okay.
That's his job,
isn't it?
Okay.
Um,
so it was,
as of recently being the last three years after moving my,
what the fuck?
So as of recently being the last three years after moving,
my mom has been the sole source of income and he's been home every day
collecting unemployment of 200 bucks,
uh,
laying on his ass doing nothing but calling up random hideous women and going
behind her back on random dating websites,
claiming things he wants to do sexually to these random women.
Jesus Christ.
Sounds like the Dwight Yoakam character in sling blade.
Get Out of my fucking house.
What'd you call the practice?
Um,
I can't stand that I've known and haven't said anything,
but I feel would crush my mom.
Yeah,
that's tough dude.
Who's now reaching 50 and being cheated on twice.
Should I tell her
oh,
twice before by other men?
Yeah,
it's a pattern.
She keeps picking the same guy,
if that's what you're saying.
By the way,
he's cheating on my mom in front of me.
Not Physically,
but he knows I know and doesn't care.
He doesn't interact with me the way a father should.
He's worthless in my opinion.
Sounds like it.
Jesus is depressing.
What should I do?
It tears me apart.
I am shamed to be known as his son.
I'm just lucky I have my mother,
my mother's father,
to look down to the t
that way I have,
oh,
I'm just lucky to have my mother's father's looked down to a t.
That way I have no physical connection with the Douche that is my father.
And don't worry,
this won't reflect on me and how I'll be when I'm a parent.
It only encourages me to do better,
dude,
I've got to tell you,
that's about all you can do.
Okay?
All right.
That's about all you could do is just learn from this situation.
Try not to repeat it.
Um,
as far as telling your mother or not telling your mother,
uh,
I dunno,
I'm going to give you bad advice here because my first thing is going to it.
I Dunno.
I kind of got angry at that dude in the middle of that and I'm going to try to
tell you to say something you shouldn't fucking say.
So I don't know how many more years I'm doing trying to do the math.
What do you got a couple more years at home?
Just fucking write it out.
Get out of that house.
I,
you know,
dude,
I don't know.
These are tough questions this week.
I don't fucking know.
What do you tell them?
If you feel like your mother's going to be able to hear that,
take it in and kicked this bum out on his.
MMM.
I mean,
there's plenty of dating sites and that type of shit out there for somebody who
was 50,
I would think at this point.
MMM.
It's gotta be some over 50,
not a bum ass piece of shit.com social networking or something.
I don't know.
I don't do that.
That's up to you.
I don't,
I mean,
I can't read two paragraphs of shit that,
that's,
that's that deep.
MMM.
Mean.
That's fucking years of shit.
God,
I sound dumb.
Look,
the best thing I got out of that is that you're looking at this stuff objective,
Lee saying,
I don't want to be that and I'm not going to be that.
Fuck that guy.
Uh,
that's what you should do.
Your events should be live in this awesome life and go out and find yourself a
great girl and build the life you want to build.
Go after your dreams.
Make some money.
All right.
Move your mother into the house at some point.
And I have a mother in law suite above the garage until that fucking bum,
he can go sit on the sidewalk because he's not invited.
They golf.
Maybe that can be your goal.
Um,
all right,
what do we got here?
I think that's it.
Is that it for this week's podcast?
Oh,
look at that.
Right in an hour.
Like fucking clockwork.
All right,
people,
I have actually,
you have to promote a couple of gigs if you don't mind.
Um,
as well as amazon.com.
You know,
as always,
I say this every week,
if you want to buy something on amazon.com,
uh,
but you know,
select to donate to this podcast.
If you go to the podcast page on bill.com B u r r and you click on the banner Ad
Amazon,
you click on that stuff,
you go to Amazon,
it's still the same price.
And they kicked me a little bit of money for sending you that way.
So you donate to the podcast that way.
And then I take a portion of those proceeds,
10% to be exact,
and I pass them on to the wounded warriors project.
And that way everybody fucking wins.
All right?
Not Saying you have to buy anything on Amazon,
but if you're Ghana,
there's a way.
There's a way to do it where everybody gets everybody.
Everybody's happy.
How's that?
Right.
Okay.
Um,
let me get to my fucking website here,
Bill Burr.
Okay.
Dot Com.
Now,
why wouldn't that pop up?
How long has it been since I've gone to my own fucking website that it doesn't
even pop up.
Server not found.
Well,
isn't that fucking wonderful?
Come on you fucking prick.
Come on.
Don't be this way.
There you go.
Shows for this week.
I'm going to be in a,
I'm going to be in Hawaii.
Some reason to date I haven't put up on my site because I'm a fucking idiot.
I'll thanks.
By the way.
February came out to flappers in Burbank on January 10th.
I had a great time trying out a bunch of new material,
weaving it in with the stuff that I knew was going to work.
Uh,
he had a great time.
puppet up.
Dot.
January,
January 26th,
I'm going to be in Hawaii doing a standup show on the 27th.
I'm going to the pro bowl.
Everybody going to the pro bowl.
Might be doing something for inside the NFL.
They're little teaser there.
All right.
Upcoming events and met the Wilbur Theater in Boston,
Massachusetts,
Thursday,
Friday and Saturday.
February.
Fucking dumb ass bill.
Dumb ass bill.
Where's the calendar when you need it?
This is what I do at the end.
I just make you guys feel smarter.
This is my lot in life.
The 21st 22nd and 23rd,
I'm going to be at the Wilbur Theater in Boston.
And guess who's featuring the one and only the teen idols sensation from the
opiate Anthony Program.
Um,
oh.
Not to mention now.
February 19th doing the,
uh,
the,
the Patrice O'Neal benefit,
which is going to be insane at the city center.
It's all sold out.
Uh,
you know,
we could give him some tickets to some friends and family.
There might be some other tickets available right before the date.
Uh,
we might release some just to let you know.
I will definitely give you the heads up on that.
I'll be at bananas in Hasbrouck Heights.
Um,
February 18th doing a benefit for a,
a good friend of mine,
Vinnie,
mark,
um,
doing a benefit for his wife as she battles a victorious battle over cancer.
And um,
other than that,
I can't even read all the rest of these dates.
I put a bunch of dates up on my website,
a Madison,
Wisconsin,
Milwaukee,
grand rapids,
Michigan,
Royal Oak,
Indianapolis,
Indiana and Minneapolis,
Minnesota,
Atlanta,
Georgia,
Dallas,
Texas,
Kansas City,
Missouri,
Los Vegas,
Nevada,
uh,
Baltimore in Easton,
Pennsylvania.
More dates to come.
And I know you're going to ask me,
you coming here,
you come in there,
the dates are going to become an [inaudible] and I'm definitely going to be
coming to Chicago.
People keep asking me about Chicago.
That's going to happen.
Philly's gonna happen.
DC's going to happen as well as a bunch of others.
I'm going to try to get to as many places as I can.
I appreciate everybody asking me to come that way.
I got a brand new hour,
his shit,
and I'm dying to go out on the road and it all starts next month.
Um,
so that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Don't take any shit.
Go fuck yourselves.
Thank you.
As always for listening and,
uh,
that is it.
I'll talk to you next week.